[Music]
police continue their efforts to
identify the body of a boy discovered
behind some bushes friday morning
hikers found the boy's body off a trail
in the town of mountain springs just off
highway 160
between las vegas and perhaps victoria
saha joins us from the newsroom victoria
spoke to the detective on the case
we understand they desperately need the
community to help
yes their focus is on nye and clark
county they do believe
someone knows who this boy is they have
crossed off any indication that this may
be a missing boy from other states
police thought they had a solid lead
when a mother claimed the sketch of the
boy was of her son
but it turned out to be a case of
misidentification a digitally enhanced
picture was provided by the national
center for missing
missing and exploited children and
police say they have received hundreds
of tips
they are encouraging teachers to take a
close look at the picture
to see if it could have been a student
however they welcome tips from
anyone no matter how big or small they
may be
he's 411 123 pounds you know if you
recognize this little boy and now you
don't see him
call the tip line we're going to go
check his welfare and we're doing that
on every tip
and you know we're so far hundreds of
doors we have knocked on
here again is a picture of the boy he
does have black hair and brown eyes and
believed to be hispanic
the boy is a victim of a homicide
however police are not releasing
information right now on how he died
reporting live from the newsroom
victoria saha 8 news now